长度96
来少腰带
29扣6
29块扣6扣6
没有腰带了
两边有斜扎口袋
藏蓝色的这一件
来这个29块扣6扣6
这个袖子也好看
这个没见过
我也很少见
是不是新款我也不知道
反正就这一件
29块扣6扣6
没有腰带少腰带
应该不是个新款
新款基本上不会少腰带
应该
没有腰带了
这个藏蓝色
29给你们
这个面料数
我看喜标还有不
哇里面都是包边包条的呢
M码巨石卷子的也是
小爱心呢
小爱心
陈哥最近没来
他应该喜欢
小黄油你喜欢吗
后面开刹
来这个29块
扣2扣2扣1
来这个
这个是一个马甲
这个是有领子的一款马甲
有领子的一个黑色
两边有纸纱口袋的一个马甲
来这个尺寸量一下
胸围
胸围的话是98
98能拉伸到
98 108长度
长度是72
这个29块太大了
是吧
好的
来这个29块
扣2扣2这个
这个是一个小西装
29块扣2扣2
来灰色
灰色全索尼又出生一条西装货
来腰尾6692
臀尾110 120
来
当场38
裤长100
这个39扣8
39块扣8扣8
灰色灰色的
39扣个8
扣个8
来这个
绵93
人绵7
绵93人绵7
这个牌子牛仔裤
灰色
工装裤这个是
破洞的呢
破洞的一条牛仔工装裤
来腰尾68
68到84
68 84
臀尾110 116
当场36
裤长99
这个上面贴了个标
这个啥
这里有一点微黄
这个腰这里有一点点微微黄
贴了个标在这里
来这个20
不得19
19扣个2
1919扣2扣2的一块
19块
扣2扣2工装破灯裤
那个腰上有一丢丢黄黄点
那个腰上有一点点黄点
19块19块
来这一块
这一块
这个前面有一排扣
这个是TCH的一个军马
学法的
来
胸围102112
一长是58
9块扣个8
9块9块扣8
扣8这一块
9块扣个8
扣8
扣9
扣10
扣11
扣12
扣13
扣14
扣15
扣16
扣17
扣18
扣19
扣20
扣22
扣23
扣24
扣25
扑25
扑26
扑27
扑28
扑30
扑31
扑32
扑33
扑34
扑35
扑36
扑37
扑38
扑39
扑40
扑41
扑42
扑43
扑44
扑45
扑46
扑47
扑48
扑49
扑50
扑51
扑52
扑53
扑54
扑55
扑56
扑57
扑58
扑59
扑60
扑61
扑62
扑63
扑64
扑65
扑67
扑68
扑69
扑70
扑71
扑72
扑73
扑74
扑55
扑56
扑57
扑58
扑59
扑60
扑61
扑62
扑63
扑64
扑65
扑67
扑68
扑69
扑70
扑71
扑72
扑73
扑74
扑75
扑76
扑78
扑79
扑80
扑72
扑83
扑84
扑85
扑86
扑96
扑97
扑98
扑99
扑90
扑92
扑93
扑94
扑95
扑96
扑97
扑98
六块九块
这个刚过到一个藏蓝色
现在又出现一个粉色
一个短袖
来这个胸围
胸围的话是九十八一一零
长度是七十
长度七十
九块扣个五
九块九块扣五扣五
这一款粉色粉色的
九块钱扣个五
刚刚过到一个蓝色
现在是一个粉色
来
L号
棉呢棉呢这个棉混纺呢
L号L号
前面的话是这个水印呢
水印呢
这个字母是胶印的
来这个尺寸量一下
胸围一零二
一零二一二零
来长度
长度六十五
这个九块扣三
九块扣三
棉混纺的一个贴
这一件
孤品孤品了
九块钱
扣三扣三
九块扣个三
来这个
这个是一个全棉一百
微领微领
后背是有胶印字母的
来胸围
胸围九十四
一一二
长度
长度六十三
九块
九块九块
扣三扣三
九块扣个三
全棉全棉一百
全棉一百的
九块扣个三
九块扣三
来这个
这个也是MOSIN的
MOSIN的一个白色的贴
微领微领
来胸围
胸围九十二
一一零
长度
长度六十九
九块
九块扣个九
九块九块扣九扣九
这里面都转续了
九块钱
八块钱
比方说
来这一款
这个短袖
这个十一码
十一码呢
这个是
人民尼龙巨指辉仿的
这一件短袖
这个是一个米色白条纹的
这个原来是一个灰蓝色的
蓝色的哪去了
不知道
来胸围
胸围是110
胸围110
长度68
来这个九块
九块扣个八
九块九块
扣八扣八这一块
九块扣个八
九块扣八
来这一条
这个是卡其色
卡其色这一条裤
前面有抽绳
后面有松拧的
然后这个裤子这里有一点粗纱线这个位置
看有一点点抽丝的感觉
有一丢
来这个腰围
腰围66
腿围106120
肝肠34
裤肠91
这个九块给你们
九块扣个一
卡其色
九块九块
扣一
这一块
九块扣个一
来这一款
这个是M码
人棉75
尼龙20
捐25
来这个蓝色
这个是孕妇裤
春秋冬裤
这一串
那毛绒绒呢
这个腰上可以调节
腰围不限
腰围可以调节的
臀围
臀围94到116
肝肠38
裤肠100
这个九块扣8
孕妇裤
九块扣8
九块九块
扣个8
抽不扣
来这一款
这个标的是一个M码
巨指65棉
连帽呢
这一款短袖
后面有胶印字母
来这个绿色
绿色的一个假 expensive
胸围102120
长度
长度58
来这个9块
9块扣个8
扣个9块扣个8
9块 够吧
9块 够可吧
够可吧
这个高厚裤又出来一条
高厚的7-8分
哎呦 完了
这个里面没有标了
36嘛
那面料超舒服
就是鲜黄说的
2万多的吊牌家的
面料好软
和长裤是一样
这个短一点
看见没
超舒服的这一条
来这个腰尾
腰尾70
70-72的腰
平尾
平尾96 106
当长33
裤长89
来这个9块
9块扣9
9块9块
扣个9
面料很丝滑很薄
是一个7-8分的
9块扣9
9块9块扣个9
来这个少抽绳
少抽绳
这个松紧不好了
工装裤男士的
工装裤
腰尾76
76-90
平尾110-116
当长37
扣长105
来这个19块给你们
扣个5
没有抽绳了
这个少抽绳
但是松紧
不是特别大了
扣你
来这个19块
扣5
不介意的扣
工装裤这个是
男生能穿
19块
扣个5
来
来这个蓝色
蓝色棉100
蓝色的一个棉100
来胸围
胸围96
一长56
这个棉95
捐着5的
看一下喜标
看一下喜标在这里
M码
棉97这个色
棉97捐指3
这个是一个藏蓝色的
一个小外套
9块钱给你们
扣3扣3
9块
9块扣个3
9块9块扣